heard someone say you need to provide  more value but what does that actually  mean so there's four components to  creating value the first is you have to  figure out the dream outcome that  somebody wants to achieve component  number two is that your prospects and  the people you're trying to sell to they  have to believe that you're actually  going to give them that outcome the  third part is how long is it gonna take  me to get that outcome the shorter you  can make the time between when they buy  and when they get the more valuable it  will become and then the fourth piece is  the effort and sacrifice that someone  has to go through in order to achieve it  the goal is to shrink that to as much as  possible so in a perfect world we'd make  an amazing promise that they believe  that they can achieve immediately with  almost no effort and when we're thinking  about value those are the four things  that go into it